yippee cayey mother rejects
the name of this episode is yippie kayak
so in this exceptionally hot room made
sure john wore the beanie from maria
hammond that's right and i wore my
sweater from maria hammond referencing
die hard for some reason john says he
can keep his jacket on in this weather
why not you know it's it's new york it's
new york in springtime it could snow at
any moment
i know how new york weather works
thanks to established titles for
sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction today if
you guys can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated and no seriously you
might see us with a couple more sponsors
because uh starting up a couple new
segments one i've already mentioned
another one that you guys have no idea
about once that's off the ground it's
gonna be exciting and then uh yeah i got
a whole bunch of shows too so gonna be
hiring the boys at prepper that much
more
so you know that's why we're getting a
little bit more partners to brand up
with to get us through the foreseeable
weeks
so support them all support them all
everyone let's do this
so just to recap you left an unmarked
package on a police captain's desk on a
random monday with a suspicious message
written on it that looked like it was
scrawled by a crazy person mm-hmm bomb
there's a bomb
of course yeah let's go
great gift babe
we literally just watched chippendale
rescue rangers which right cos
on our end here today that's my boy
reaction next
little nicky reaction after that no
that's adam sandler your real present
arrives tomorrow there's more charles
this is too much nonsense it was just a
lot of time and a lot of money wow
[Laughter]
gina i screwed up i forgot to get
charles anything oh well i always knew
he would die of sadness such a selfish
jerk ooh i could call up one of those
kids and offer them a free trip to new
york i wouldn't do that right cause i'm
a stranger and i shouldn't be luring
them out of state good call
please come with me please i need help
picking something up please gina i'll
take a pic of terry in the locker room
for you no towel with his foot up on the
bench towel on still wet from the shower
i'm in
guys what's up nothing
you're always cold you brought a blanket
to a mets game in mid-july
this one thinks july 18th is mid-july
and i'm strong
and i love to splash around in chilly
water it's not chilly this is cold as
the waters of cochitis the frozen lake
of hell i'll see you there
i can't wait to dunk my junk
oh
yes oh no using that i've got two days
of family time do not attempt to contact
me i do not want a repeat of last year
when scully called me 50 times on
christmas morning somebody's got a lot
of business attention
who are you barbara corcoran
i'm clearly laurie nobody call me i
don't understand that reference the
comments will explain tell me jake who
should pour sack at the bottom of your
list
actually amy amy
that's bad
just give her whatever you got me really
but then i wouldn't have a gift for you
would you be cool with that no that
would eviscerate me
i'll get my coat i'm gonna help you oh
no
they locked the doors but if you're
still inside you get an extra 15 minutes
to finish up so we should just try and
sneak in an entrance through the back
boyle you'll have to stay here it's too
dangerous no way i'll let you take that
risk alone damn it you are loyal
shall we
it worked cologne uh it's perfume for a
lady woman it's called canyon stink it's
got a man writing a burrow on it ugh
does it i didn't notice i just like the
way it smelled i wear this cologne jake
i'm a stink man um
oh i wanted amy to smell more like you
okay little creepy bud coming on real
strong wow the tables have really turned
keep walking
shoot the store is being robbed good
thing they were there
whoa this is really cinematic
stealing the exits oh my god
it's real life
we don't need guns i have a lighter okay
we get some hairspray make some flame
throwers let's fry these [ __ ]
can't get in touch with anyone from the
nine-nine right amy rose and holt are
having the time of their lives splashing
around in the freezing filthy ocean i'll
try terry oh no
thank you for the food in front of us
why would you have your phone there
number one priority terry
there are multiple gunmen they've
blocked all the exits they've taken the
security guards hostage and we're
looking for a place to hide
it's awesome
awesome awesomely serious
stupid the important thing is keep gina
safe you have a civilian with you i'm on
the way cool oh also bring a pic of
yourself in a towel coming out of the
shower can't explain why okay gotta go
bite
did one of your detectives lose his head
of his own butt
you don't even have a job zeke i'm sick
of hearing you got things brewing the
only thing you got brewing is a pot of
bs
kids i love you sharon you are perfect z
get a job
[Laughter]
way to go terry well done tear into him
i think his eyes got a little teary
after that someone has to assess the
situation boyle plus we're trapped on
christmas with a bunch of bad guys who
are very likely german this is my john
mcclane moment okay
you're gonna need a tank top he could
have mine no need i snagged this on the
way here oh god i'll probably just skip
the tank yeah i will return
okay gina
it looks pretty cold i'm not i'm
actually hot
cotton ready to get this super fun thing
over with first a toast great let's drag
this out
i'm reminded of a beloved christmas
carol by english poet christina rosetti
in the bleak
[Laughter]
a stone moonstone phone we get it down
the hatch let's get this over with
god
[Applause]
oh
you tried got two detectives and a
civilian in there who's in charge i am
ding dong
oh
no
no
happy kwanzaa
oh man you can't say that
all right let's see what we're dealing
with
hmm
i'll call you
klaus
you will be gunter
dot's over the u
and umlaut
here's the situation 12 terrorists one
cop just the way he likes it i saw that
video online that's the tagline from the
die hard poster and also my high school
yearbook quote all right you know i
recognize it next time lead with that
right sorry also there aren't 12 of them
there are seven and they're not
terrorists they're robbers they brought
drilling equipment to break into the
sink
[Laughter]
two cops and one gina yes exactly
where's gina
oh no
she went for the hairspray she is
incorporable
who are you come here
jake they're taking gina i know we're
looking at the same thing
[Laughter]
what they got gina i told you to watch
her i know he's the black cop outside
ask the vulture to give me some more
time he'll be reasonable what am i
talking about it's the vulture tell him
tila tequila is doing a free show in
central park then how comptilo just
posted a selfie from the kid rock show
i'll give him a chance to sit on his
little white butt and wait for me to
come rescue him you tell him that i'm
liam neeson and he's my hot dumb
daughter oh god
[Music]
now i have a mannequin arm
nice work yeah
where are you holding the hostages i bet
you'd like to know a canadian
uh yeah i was ooh but now i'm back eh
meet me in the service corridor we've
got a situation with the hostages
okey-dokey sorry to hear about that
i can't do it i'm a wimp just like you
said i didn't say that and i don't care
if you go in be honest
judging me i'm really not
oh
what
oh
oh
guys captain rosa oh please hear me from
land
uh
oh my god oh my god
oh welcome to the phone
how are we gonna get past some of that
gunfight i'll tell you how john mclean
would do it
the vets
ah
blast they see they get chilly they
leave with fine sweaters no we're gonna
climb them
would have some sweats
they leave them find sweaters
i think we're good
yes
how are you tied up i'm scared
this guy hasn't stopped farting for the
last hour
kevin feige
meet the strangest people in new york
you're a cop
i hate cops
they give me this
nice finally a good bad guy this dude
gets it
i've killed 10 men and that's such a
nice round number when you agree i mean
imagine i've killed 11 people it just
sounds so
cumbersome
did it
and you completely botched the
catchphrase i'm pretty sure it was right
yippee kayak mother buckets i got so
excited knocked the headphones off so
good
drill it's not for the safe they're
using it to tunnel out of here and those
farts gina kept smelling uh they were
ramon no it was sewage
or ramone
merry christmas ho ho ho i'm starving
i'm starving
i'm starving
jake
i'm so glad you're okay
wow you're really worried about me
mm-hmm oh so your face is so warm and i
think i have hypothermia
[Music]
it was all jake and charles hmm spoken
like a true captain
also you are in trouble you're suspended
one week
but you've got a bright
i future take some time off but i did
get canning stink gift set it's all
three stanks
[Laughter]
i didn't forget amy's gift i forgot
yours
the canyon stank was for you what
why didn't you just tell me
oh because it would have crushed my
heart and ruined our friendship good
call
[Laughter]
merry christmas buddy you too buddy
excellent
oh damn what a delight
damn yippee kayak mother buckets that
was good
it's good brooklyn nine-nine succeeds
again
knew they had it in them yep
that was good that was a episode
jake living the dream can't live the
dream of
being able to
fulfill some
action hero fantasies every guy i know
wants to be an action hero in some way
it's the ultimate fantasy
but to put in the work
no that's
that's too much
you know it's another fantasy of mine
what's that to become a scottish lord
ooh hey i know how you can do that
we're gonna need you boys and girls to
become a lord right now now you're
probably thinking isn't a lord some type
of royalty i will not when you check out
today's video sponsor established titles
they come in a big scottish alert has
never been easier established title
packs come with at least one square foot
of dedicated land and a nifty
certificate with your unique plot number
so you can look upon the exact location
of your land they work with multiple
global reforestation charities and plot
a tree with every other plus they make
great last minute gifts you can
officially change your name to lord or
lady and even put it on a credit card or
a plane ticket established titles is
running a bag sale right now bagpipes
and if you use the code real rejects
you'll get an additional 10 percent off
your order so go to establishtitles.com
rio rejects my card and officially
change your name to lord or lady today
hey guys
now that we're lords now that we're
deemed lords
or ladies you know doesn't matter
this was a delightful episode i thought
i loved the reversal at the end with uh
boiled
yes
with charles becoming the what to be the
john mcclane of it all
just dropping through the van
wife beat her tank top wife feeder
that's a [ __ ] issue that is for so
weird all of my life i have wondered how
and why that became the acceptable term
maybe the sun magazine when
calling johnny depp that they were like
we were just talking about his shirt he
wears a lot of those shirts what do you
want from us like what's wrong why was
that defamation yeah that's the big deal
um
yeah uh i
like that with charles this this is
i like that it just really honed in on
the
again it's kind of like echoing
statements i said about the chippendale
movie
is it honed in on the on the genre of it
and it kept that really exciting and
felt like it felt like a nose die hard
without just doing a parody of die hard
it did the
things of die hard without parodying die
hard weirdly yeah because he just wants
it to be tired but it's not anywhere
near diamond yeah and i feel like that's
enough and i feel like that's a very
smart choice a for the budget b for the
length c for the amount of you know
i like that this episode like you
pointed out like did have more of sort
of a cinematic and intense visual flair
but you know there's only so much you
can change the visual style of show like
this that gets produced week to week and
yeah i thought that was a great choice
because if you know die hard you're
gonna have fun but it's not like you'll
only have fun if you recognize this beat
and that character it's like you point
out with terry out front it's just
enough you know yeah it's just enough to
have the ally out front to have that nod
or whatever and then the things that get
changed are fun because those are the
subversions i'm surprised we didn't see
any of the z thing come back around i
know
so it was it was a rule of two joke yeah
it feels like there should have been a
third beat
yeah i felt like it would probably have
been a longer episode mm-hmm this could
have been a 45-minute episode i almost
feel like yeah that even if it was great
yeah i still thought it was great but
yeah i think i would have been totally
fine with a 45-minute special christmas
episode or something oh my god i want
that timeline yeah and i i wouldn't be
surprised if i wouldn't expect that they
did that but i wouldn't be surprised if
this had some scenes cut out or or stuff
for time yeah because i did like to see
them being like badasses in the field
with actually using
you know strategy and weapons around
them and like outsmarting people yeah
just like holding people up and freeze
you know yeah well that's that's the
thing too is that's the right level of
like okay like they're goofy and stuff
but when it comes time to really handle
business they can work as a team and
they can get it done
you know like they they know how to
temper the silliness so that it's just
the characters personalities but they
actually are competent i really like
gino the whole flame though everything i
like that gina wasn't scared at all
yeah and even when she was i mean still
in a gina way which is not really much
yeah yeah i thought the trio of them was
a really good choice like to have that
go yeah of like oh i forgot boyle's gift
and then have this like uncomfortable
situation that you might already get
into with some friends and then to
isolate those three
and even the way that they played with
rosa and holt and amy and using that as
a means of sort of foiling them but then
also getting them back onto the scene
finally and having amy have to overcome
her fear of the cold yeah you know i
thought that was nice like that was a
nice sidebar b plot that i thought
joined the a plot in a fun way and same
with terry you know it's like you start
out with this prospect of like okay his
story is about him wanting to take some
time off and actually just be at home
but then you know the way that dovetails
into the main plot and everything kind
of meets up i thought was really nice
and gratifying i love the vulture in
this one yeah
too and he's the perfect character to
come and be the [ __ ] you know like
guy who's heading up the you know
situation who you know are who are terry
in this situation or the or the cop in
die hard you know ultimately have to
rise above like yeah and it doesn't feel
in the moment like well you know they're
they're doing the gimmick it just feels
like a part of the show yeah yeah yeah
thousand percent yeah this is really
well realized and and really well
encompassing of just the characters and
world they built
um
and even andy like jake being excited
doesn't undercut things
no because this is exactly what he's
always won yeah and i thought that was
really charming to watch him train his
whole life for this moment yeah and even
by proxy then boyle was excited and
trying to help him get the moment yeah
yeah
it was really nice
this was just a really this was firing
on all this is one of those episodes of
fires on all cylinders yeah i think the
b plot of the of the
amy and the water thing is
kind of
so brief and a little
odd
but i still enjoyed it it feels yeah i
mean and that's that goes back to me to
that thing of like i feel like there was
probably more for both of those b plots
but the ultimate
point and the ultimate you know thing is
this diehard scenario so yeah it's like
i would have taken a little bit more
from each of those but i did think
everything at the beach was funny yeah
the whole toast bit and everything was
was really hilarious
ah
well gang
gippy kayak they they knocked it out of
the park again they did
fantastic work here from the people at
brooklyn nine-nine i'm a general
a nice yeah it's what every die hard is
about yep
i don't want to be a mclean i just want
to go live with mom i'm a generous stop
wreaking havoc dad hey show respect i'm
sorry
hey big respect to the bruce
yeah
all his movies are now good every
movie
including once from before where it
seemed like he didn't care are good and
it's gonna all be chalked up to that now
yes yes die hard five is now my favorite
they're all my favorite
all right guys we'll see you around
thanks for being here
[Music]